One of the challenges of building new
technologies is that we often want them
to solve things that have been very
socially difficult to solve; things that
we don't have answers to; problems that
we don't know how we would best go about
it in a socially responsible way.
Technology cannot fill that gap for us.
In fact technology is more likely than
not, and artificial intelligence in
particular, to exacerbate existing
challenges. So if we look at different
issues where we have major social
challenges ahead of us, whether that is
in the business realm, in criminal
justice, in medicine, in education, we
need to think hard and deep about how we
want to marry technology and artificial
intelligence into the broader social
challenges that we're seeing with those
systems. Artificial intelligence in many
ways right now means different things to
different people. For the technical
community it's a very particular and
narrow set of technologies, very much
focused on neural networks, or
advanced machine learning techniques, or
robotics of a particular ilk. And these
kinds of techniques have been in
development for an extended period of
time, so most technical folks are
thinking about the iterations, the
evolutions, the histories of that. For the
business community, artificial
intelligence has become the new buzzword,
the idea of being able to do magical
things with large amounts of data to
solve problems that have in many ways
become socially intractable that we hope that
we can solve through technical means.
For the public,
AI really refers to the imagination
that computers can do crazy things, and
those crazy things can be both positive
solving the world's problems, you know
coming down and computers appearing to
be smart.
They can also be absolutely terrifying
and usually there we refer to Hollywood
concepts to really come back to it.
One of the most important things to do when
we start to study artificial
intelligence is to actually bring together
different frameworks of thinking. We need
to think about it both technically and
socially. And the main reason is because
the biggest problems ahead of us are not
simply technical or simply social. In
fact it's the marriage between the two
that becomes the most important. For this
reason we have to take different kinds
of social issues very seriously.
We have
to really understand what's at stake, the
biases of the data that are involved in making artificial intelligence
function, the interpretation layers, the
ways in which these systems can get
manipulated. All of these social issues
become critical to making certain that
the technologies are done right. The key
and challenge of figuring out how to think
ethically is to actually think about how
we want to marry different kinds of
social mindsets and different kinds of
technical mindsets. How do we get the
technical folks to start articulating
the realm of possibilities that are
available to us? And what are the
governance structures that we want to
see in place to make certain that we can
choose responsibly?
We're entering a realm where we're paying a lot
of attention to cybersecurity, where we're
realizing that the security of our
infrastructure can put us at risk in
tremendous ways. The same will be true of
artificial intelligence, but the risks
that we have faced aren't necessarily
about traditional hacking. They're about
the manipulation of data, about data
being misinterpreted in different ways,
about the ways of cleaning and
processing that data to do analysis, not
taking into account certain social
issues. And so this means we need to
really think about the whole process in
which we produce artificial intelligence
systems.